こんにちははじめ社長です a
お久しぶりです8月ですね珍しくほぼ満員
つい動画を更新させていただいてちょっと
空月に入ってまぁ若干落ち着いて何か他の
活動したちょっとゆっくりしたりとか色々
ご僕の中がやりたいことがあってそういう
のをやる時間にさせていただいたいったと
かなんかどうだとは別の遺書が c 完全
にはなっているんですけれどもあの元気に
しておりますこんにちははじめた超です8
月中にですねちょっと事件みたいなことは
実はありましてなんかタイミングがなくて
8月中はちょっと言えなかったんですけど
もうちょっと9月のこの落ち着いたたい
見上げてようやくちょっとお話しさせて
いただければなと思います何て言えばいい
んでしょうねちょっと
も今実際にその場に行ったわけじゃないと
わからないんですけれども2月のニーズ
さんに5
の8 c 22時45分これぐらいの時間
帯からぼくのおうちに
boku no g ですね不審な人物が
いました
静岡の方の方中です3億円の号店のほうで
ちょっと不審査というか怪しい人が
いたという姉でいる鳥3億円の僕の家
セキュリティがかなり強化されていまして
幹事会あの台詞でもかなりあります僕の家
に侵入しようと思ったら即にしただけでも
もうすぐ録画されています実際に録画され
ていますのでちょっと実際の見させて
いただきますちょっと特定されないに伏せ
させていただくんですけどどうぞ亜衣時田
ご覧くださいこれ以上僕の家の前ですね
越冬
正面っていう言い方がいいんですか
正面という感じだっていますはい多くから
人が
人影が見えるがわかりますでしょうか
ほんと何かゆっくり近づいてますね
もどったのか
すぎな動きしてるの
完全この時点でも
僕の所有地の中にいますねこれ普通に
アウトです
でもう息ピンポンでしょう
ぐるぐるっと
いやいや普通にも強いんだよなぁ
見てますねー
中の様子をうかがっています
ソジンの扉がちょっと半開きみたいになっ
てるんですけども
国光一応なんか動かなドアが今しっかり
閉鎖されていただいてるんですけど
半田っぽく見えて動かないんですけどネコ
語無理やりこじ開けようとしてるんですよ
見てもらったら分かるともですけどもほら
もう
無理に入ろうとせて家の中に
ダメでしょう
不法侵入が普通に正直これ初めて見た時
声出なかったですね
うわぁもほら全身に力入れてドア着ようと
するんですよこの後をしばらくずっとこの
道 akio としています
ちょっとわからんなぁ
湧かない
ってわかったのかなって話しましたねにし
てるのこの人
そして強くて俺も今初めてじっくり見てる
んですけど
いやー
止めてよ本当に人の嫌は着ようとしてため
でしょもうずーっとちゃってるんですよ
なんでそんな中4時間できるんだ
もう大体をさせだと思うんですけどもこれ
だけじゃない時間
知らない人の家の動画が来脅してる時点で
もちょっとただ事ではないなと思いますよ
ね長いよそもそも吸っちゃダメなことだし
ずっとやってるのがやばいー
諦めたはのこれでも全然ダメなんですけど
もまぁここからまだ続くわけなんですよ
もう全部取られてるからねぇ
鬱で変なことさせようとしたら
でおりさと動画だすからこれが正面銀冠や
にハイロードしてた映像でもう一個あり
ます
はい裏にも来ました
スマホでなんか触りながらやってんだよな
きょろきょろして困難なにスマホで何をし
てるんだろう
でも前が無理だってわかってから裏から
細部
試みをされているみたいでなんかずっと家
のその喧嘩にあるも触ったりしてるんです
よ
乗り込みますった
敵国から迫られてずっと僕の家の
人間の前で縛られていましたで大体20分
ぐらいずっと1触られてしばらくしてから
警察の方が来てくださって
まぁ色々とこれ
一段落したという言い方が正しいか分から
ないんですけどもちゃんと連れて行って
頂きましたはいっていうのは8月末に北の
王5ds で実際にあった話ですねなんか
ですねこういうこと動画にしないといいん
ですけどもチャットうちセキュリティ万全
というか何かあったらすぐ警察の方が来
られますしてちゃんとこうやって感じた女
に取られてるよっていうのぜひ皆さんにお
伝えしたかったですこれボク黒 f 3型
姉にいなかったから良かったものの
たまたのゆるに外で忠勝合わせにしたら何
されてるかわかんないわけですよ東京にで
本当によかったなっていうのもありますし
が結構言ってたじゃないですか
前に住んでる家でもお家に来るが家に来
ないでくださいとか来る人を通報したりと
か今回さ受けノーツに引越する時も
セキュリティ万全なので本当に超えて
くださいできたらすぐ警察沙汰にします
からってこれだけしつこく言ってるよ
かかわらず
もう
監視カメラ写ってるも気にせず堂々家の
ドアをこじ開けようとする方が今回
いました縁とか怒っていたそういう肝臓
よりもどっちかどぅ恐怖ですね雪の言葉が
出ないですねそういう子の方が全く見え
知識がない方で誰かも分からないですし
心当たりもない方が何かお話聞くと盗みと
か窃盗とかそういう目的じゃなく長さんっ
て言うかはわからないですけどもなんか
どっちかというと会いに来たという感じ
珍しいですまぁ理由はなんですよ僕がこの
動画絶対のは僕の家にかかわらず他の家に
も絶対しないでほしいんですけども僕に
そこら辺すっごい厳しいんでもうその人に
どんな理由があろうといやっちゃいけない
ことはやっちゃいけないと思うのでいませ
ん今回これで10日にさせていただきまし
た
いや偉人に行ったらまずで
すごいなぁ映って良かったんだろうな
こういう監視カメラとかもう本当にながら
家の前でウロチョロ下げているだけの強い
のにもうはっきりと映像として家のドアを
6ディ開けようとして家の中で神入賞をし
ているということでちょっとかなり怖かっ
たです
やめてくださいまだマンだけでかいおうち
なので家の居場所ぱれてるなも仕方ない
部分なんですけどもそうだからしっかり
セキュリティとが感じかなとかそういう
切り態勢もんしっかりしてるねほんとに
悪いんですけどまたこういうことだったら
した人の gk がぶっ壊されちゃうんで
ぜひ上げていただけるとありがたいですね
なんで男女に俺が家の朝の近所の人たち
ですよ近所の人たちがこういうで怖い思い
したりなんかその僕が住んでいることに
よって嫌な思いさけれど本当にやる盟約
絶対かけたくないんでそれが本当に一番嫌
ですねそれも嫌なわけしっかりとこうやっ
て動画にしていいかの悪いですけども
もちろんちゃんと隠すべき部分を隠す
けれどもしっかり晒してみたでしょさんと
警察に連れてかれるところがコーナーに
よっていうのをぜひみなさんにお伝えし
たかったです悪ふざけではなんか軽い
気持ちで来たのかでも僕ずっと許さないん
で夜行バッドわぁのこれがそっちにも強
すぎて僕にかかわらず人のお家に勝手に
たりだとかこういう声は是非やめて
くださいというのが毛髪月火この受験
みたいな感じですねじゃあ
なって戻りますじゃあ
あっ
[音楽]
は bl